.
>> Hannity: I'M HAVING A HARD
TIME KEEPING UP WITH THIS.
ALL RIGHT TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FEELING A LITTLE TURN IN YOUR
STOMACH WHICH MARKED MIDTERMS
ONLY SIX DAYS AWAY.
CONDITIONS LOOK RIGHT FOR A
MAJOR RED WAVE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR
ANYTHING POLLYANNAISH ON THIS
PROGRAM.
I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
OVERPROMISING AND UNDER
DELIVERING.
DEALER THINGS GET A MATTER THAT
IS WHAT HAPPENS AT THE POLLS AND
THAT WILL BE NEXT TUESDAY.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN, MAKE NO
MISTAKE.
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
RESULTS ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT.
WE'LL KNOW THE RESULTS HOPEFULLY
IN ALL STATES.
FIVE SENATE RACES IN MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN HOUSE RACES ARE WITHIN
TWO POINTS.
THIS IS WHY I'M NOT
POLLYANNAISH, WHY DON'T WANT TO
CREATE A CONDITION WHERE PEOPLE
ARE OVERLY ENTHUSIASTIC.
WITHIN TWO POINTS.
THAT'S FIVE STATES.
THAT'S WITHIN THE BALANCE OF
POWER IN CONGRESS.
A FEW THOUSAND VOTES CAN DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT JOE BIDEN AND HIS
RADICAL LEFT DEMOCRAT SOCIAL
PARTY WILL HAVE KEY CONTROL OVER
YOUR GOVERNMENT.
OTHER RACES ARE WITHIN TWO
POINTS INCLUDING IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK.
ALL THE RACES ARE TIGHT.
IN 2016, THICK ABOUT THIS, POLLS
SHOWED DONALD TRUMP LOSING
HANDILY AND THEN HE SHOCKED THE
WORLD AND WON THE ELECTION IF
YOU LOOK AT THREE KEY STATES IN
2016 THEY WERE AT WERE DECIDED
BY A COMBINED 77,000 VOTES IN
2020, THE MARGIN FOR JOE BIDEN
WHICH IS 43,000 VOTES AND THREE
SWING STATES DESPITE THE ABSURD
PROJECTIONS.
JOE CARRIED ARIZONA FOR EXAMPLE
BY LESS THAN HALF A POINT.
AS YOU MIGHT'VE NOTICED, WITH A
FEW NOTABLE EXCEPTIONS, MOST
POLLS IN THE LAST DECADE HAVE
BEEN UTTER GARBAGE.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOUR VOTE IS
WHAT MATTERS.
IF OTIS MADE BOWL.
IF YOU DON'T TURN OUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MACHINE WILL
WIN AND THAT WOULD BE A DISASTER
FOR YOU, OUR COUNTRY, OUR KIDS,
OUR GRANDKIDS.
WE CAN'T AFFORD ANOTHER TWO
YEARS OF DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
RULE.
ANYONE WITH A PULSE KNOWS THIS
COUNTRY IS NOW SUFFERING FROM
POLICIES THAT HAVE DONE
IRREPARABLE HARM TO OUR ECONOMY,
OUR BORDERS, AND EVEN YOUR DAILY
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
IN THE SHADOW OF THE ELECTION,
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW PLAYING THE
BLAME GAME.
ACCORDING TO THEM, THEY PLAYED
NO ROLE IN MANY OF THE CRISES
THEY THEMSELVES CAUSED -- NOT
THE BORDER CRISIS, THE FENNEL
CRISIS, THE OPIOID CRISIS, THE
INFLATION CRISIS, THE HIGH GAS
PRICE CRISIS, OR THE CRISIS OF
CONFIDENCE THAT ARE SCHOOLS.
ALL THESE EVIL, SUBHUMAN, MEGA
MEGA MEGA REPUBLICANS ARE TO
BLAME FOR ALL OF OUR TROUBLES,
ALL YOUR WOES, ACCORDING TO
JOE BIDEN.
IF YOU'RE FEELING SAD, BLAME
MEGA MEGA REPUBLICANS.
THEY HAVE A TOP-SECRET PLAN,
TALK ABOUT A CONSPIRACY THEORY,
TO END MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY AND ELIMINATE
THE VA AND ABOLISH DEMOCRACY.
TONIGHT, ONCE AGAIN, JOEY
DELIVERED ANOTHER KIND OF
BIZARRE, OUT OF TOUCH SPEECH
ABOUT HIS FULL ON HATRED FOR
HALF THE COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NOW, EXTREME MEGA REPUBLICANS
AIM TO QUESTION NOT ONLY THEIR
LEGITIMACY OF PAST ELECTIONS,
BUT ELECTIONS BEING HELD NOW AND
INTO THE FUTURE.
THIS IS THE TROUBLE WHEREIN.
IT'S A STRUGGLE FOR DEMOCRACY,
FOR DECENCY AND DIGNITY, FOR
PROSPERITY AND PROGRESS.
A STRUGGLE FOR THE VERY SOUL OF
AMERICA ITSELF.
IT'S ALSO THE FIRST ELECTION
SINCE THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6,
WHEN THE ARMED, ANGRY MOB
STORMED THE U.S. CAPITAL.
I WISH I COULD SAY THAT THE
ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY ENDED THAT
DAY, BUT I CANNOT.
>> Hannity: IN FAIRNESS TO
JOEY, HE GETS AN ICE-CREAM CONE
TONIGHT, BECAUSE HE REALLY DID
WELL.
HE REMEMBERED THE WORD, MEGA
MEGA REPUBLICAN.
THAT'S A CLOSING ARGUMENT FOR
DEMOCRATS, MEGA MEGA REPUBLICANS
ARE EVIL AND EVERY DAY IS
JANUARY 6.
LATE-TERM ABORTION UP TO THE
MOMENT OF BIRTH IS OKAY.
JOE'S CONSPIRACY THEORY BY THE
WAY, THAT REPUBLICANS WANT TO
TAKE AWAY YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
AND MEDICARE, WHAT AN UPLIFTING
MESSAGE FULL OF LIES.
AS HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF PUT
IT, REPUBLICANS ARE SO HORRIBLE
THAT THEY SHOULD BE DISQUALIFIED
FROM EVEN VOTING.
IF YOU'RE MEGA MEGA REPUBLICAN,
YOU SHOULDN'T EVEN BE ALLOWED TO
VOTE.
TAKE A LOOK AT.
>> TELL ME HOW THE ATTACK ON
PAUL PELOSI STRUCK YOU AND WHAT
DID IT TELL YOU ABOUT THE STATE
OF THE RIGHT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THE HATE TOWARD A POWERFUL
WOMAN?
>> WELL I THINK YOUR QUESTION
KIND OF ANSWERS ITSELF, JOY.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A STREAK OF
VIOLENCE, OF RACISM, MISOGYNY,
ANTI-SEMITISM AS YOU SAID.
WERE SEEING A WHOLE POLITICAL
PARTY AND THOSE WHO SUPPORTED
IT, THOSE WHO ENABLE IT, THOSE
WHO RUN UNDER ITS BANNER,
ENGAGING IN BEHAVIOR THAT IS SO
DANGEROUS.
I FIND FRANKLY IT IS
DISQUALIFYING BEHAVIOR FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
>> Hannity: DISQUALIFYING.
OKAY.
I SHARE EVERYONE'S CONCERN ABOUT
PAUL PELOSI.
I DON'T WANT ANYONE IN AMERICA
TO BE ATTACKED AS VICIOUSLY AS
HE WAS.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE DOZENS OF
AMERICANS THAT DIED IN THE
RIOTING IN THE SUMMER OF 2020.
THE THOUSANDS OF COPS THAT WERE
INJURED WITH ROCKS AND BRICKS
AND BOTTLES AND MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN PROPERTY DAMAGE.
NO DEMOCRAT SPOKE OUT ABOUT THAT
VIOLENCE OF THE RHETORIC AROUND
THAT VIOLENCE.
AND WE WERE LIED TO BY A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT THESE WERE
PEACEFUL PROTESTS, OR THEY SAID
NOTHING AT ALL.
OR THEY TWEETED UP BAIL FUNDS TO
GET THOSE PEOPLE RIOTING OUT
BACK ON THE STREET, LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS.
ECHOING HILLERY'S VENOM TELLING
HER FRIENDS THAT HALF THE
COUNTRY LIVES IN A SLIMY LITTLE
DARK CORNER, WHERE ALL THEY DO
IS LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT'S WHERE THE PARTY OF THE
REPUBLICANS LIVES.
THEY LIVE IN THAT RELEASE SLIMY
LITTLE DARK CORNER, WHERE ALL
THEY WANT TO DO IS LIE.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS APPEAL
DEGREE EVENTS, TO THE WORST
COMMON DENOMINATOR.
>> Hannity: I WONDER IF PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO THINK REPUBLICANS
ARE EVIL.
IS THAT HATE LANGUAGE WHICH
MARKED DANGEROUS RHETORIC?
THEY'RE BLAMING YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WEREN'T SPITTING WITH RAGE
WHEN GAS PRICES WERE SPIKING.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARRY FED
NINE STRAIGHT MONTHS OF A 41
YEAR HIGH IN INFLATION, NOT
THROUGH THE WEREWOLF.
THEY DIDN'T CARE WHEN BABY FOOD
WENT MISSING FROM THE SHELVES,
ABOUT THE RISING VIOLENT CRIME,
THEY DON'T EQUATE IT TO THEIR
IDIOTIC POLICIES OF DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, AND NO BAIL.
WHEN KIDS WERE KEPT OUT OF
SCHOOL, THEY DIDN'T CARE, BUT
NOW THEY'RE MAD BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT LOSE POWER.
SO I'LL CONCLUDE WITH AN
IMPORTANT REMINDER FOR
DEMOCRATS: THIS IS IN THE GAME.
THIS IS NOT AN EPISODE OF THE
WEST WING.
YOUR HORRIBLE POLICIES HAVE HAD
REAL CONSEQUENCES ESPECIALLY ON
AMERICA'S POOR AND MIDDLE-CLASS
AND PEOPLE IN FIXED INCOME.
FOR EXAMPLE, ON OCTOBER 4, IN
THE STATE OF NEW YORK, A
CONVICTED FELON WITH A HISTORY
OF VIOLENCE WAS ARRESTED FOR
ASSAULT AFTER BEATING HIS WIFE.
THANKS TO THE STATES ZERO BAIL
LAWS, 24 HOURS LATER HE WAS
RIGHT BACK OUT ON THE STREETS
AND HE PROCEEDED TO THEN EXECUTE
HIS WIFE IN FRONT OF HER KIDS.
KATHY HOCHUL, DO YOU CARE TO
COMMENT?
BECAUSE YOU SUPPORT THESE
POLICIES.
IS THAT THE DATA DEVALUED
TALKING ABOUT, KATHY?
WOULD SHE EVER VENTURED DOWN
INTO THE NEW YORK CITY SUBWAY
SYSTEM ALONE WITHOUT SECURITY.
I TEND TO DOUBT IT.
THIS IS NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
PEOPLE ARE DYING BECAUSE DEFINE,
DISMANTLE, NO BAIL LAWS.
THE VICTIM'S MOTHER IN THIS CASE
IS ACTUALLY BLAMING THE
GOVERNOR, TELLING
"THE NEW YORK POST," SHE SHOULD
BE SURE CHARGE FOR THE CRIME SHE
IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CRIME.
AND IT'S TIME TO RESUME SATURDAY
AT THE LOCAL STATE FEDERAL